Should I hold off on copy? And it was since these make them leading worse the pair of the parasites. Yeah, I would too. I'd, I'd pause that as well.
And, and pulse that as well. You know, it's so well in so many other ways.
It's just pulse that maybe just pause copy animals for a period of time.
So, you know, understand, I mean, I, I don't do copy animals anymore.
I did a couple months ago. I did several days in a row and months before that.
But then I probably went six months without doing a copy animal. So, it's, you know, I, you know, I feel like I've been remissioned.
So, I'm just, you know, I just, I don't do them on a regular basis. I didn't do them on a very regular basis.
So sick. I thought I was going to die. So, I, you know, there's nothing wrong with pulse seed things like coffee animals. I haven't had a sauna for a while.
That's going to do what today.
You don't want to make your treatment, your God, and you, you want to, okay, you're doing this treatment to go better.
Live your life, enjoy your life, follow what God has for you, and down the next days are, you know, see, turn for the worst again.
They get back on your protocols and do what you're supposed to do and trust God for the answers again.
You